this episode is brought to you by tonal
that's t-o-n-a-l
tonal is the world's most intelligent
home gym and personal trainer
that's the tagline from their website
folks so it gives you the one sentence
summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen
tv it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge
gym for like cable chop and lift or
rotational exercises and it allows me to
do other things
that are nearly impossible otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer
it uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger
faster one of my friends who used to be
a competitive skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonal's patented
digital weight system makes thousands of
calculations a second to deliver you a
smooth
weightlifting experience using their
advanced electronic motor technology
and a lot of the buttons are built right
into the handles themselves
into the grips so you don't need to move
around and
it is extremely easy to use tonal lets
you adjust the weight in one pound
increments and you can do it on the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down with just the touch
of a button
tonal also has built-in dynamic weight
modes like
chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example bicep curl
15 pounds up and then lower
automatically 20
25 pounds down and it is incredible
how much you can get done in just a
handful of minutes
when you use this type of technology so
check it out
tri-tonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home and if
you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com
t-o-n-a-l dot com and for a limited time
get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim21 tim21
tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they're worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things
that's why i use the theragun i use it
at night i use
it after workouts it is a handheld
percussive therapy device that releases
your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my
feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis i will
have my girlfriend use it up and down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her
it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to
use and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n
there's no substitute for the gen 4
theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragon.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today
or you can watch the videos on the site
which show you all sorts of different
ways to use it
a lot of runner friends of mine use them
on their i.t bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start at
just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i ask you a personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of
the tim ferriss show i'm nervous i'll
explain why i'm nervous in a minute my
guest
he's a very friendly fellow he's not
trying to make me nervous
his name is chris bosh on twitter at
chris bosh
he fell in love with basketball at an
early age and earned the prestigious mr
basketball title while still in high
school that was at lincoln high school
in dallas texas not far from where we
are sitting
in austin texas a mcdonald's
all-american bosch was selected fourth
overall by the toronto raptors after one
year
of attending georgia tech by the end of
his basketball career he was an 11 time
that's more fingers than you have folks
11 time
nba all-star two-time champion and the
nba's first
global ambassador of basketball in march
of 2019
bosch's number one jersey was officially
retired for the miami heat
in addition to his basketball career
bosch founded the community uplift
organization
team tomorrow in 2010 and regularly
speaks to youth about the benefits of
reading
coding and leadership bosch his wife
adrian and their five children reside
here in austin texas his new book
is letters to a young athlete which
includes a forward by pat riley
chris bosh can be found in many places
online twitter as mentioned at chris
bosh instagram
chris bosh and facebook official chris
bosh
chris cb welcome to the show
appreciate it man i'm i'm excited to be
here i was looking at
the copious notes in front of me i was
joking that i feel like the main
character memento
i don't like to show how the sausage is
made but this is uh the first in-person
interview
since covid for me really certainly uh
indoors
and i'm looking at this bio and i'm
looking and i'm looking and i'm looking
did you ever go to the olympics
i went to the olympics yes i thought so
i'm not
i may not be the best researcher but i i
thought that that
and uh how did things go at the olympics
amazing
yeah what was that what was the outcome
you know the olympics were one of those
things
i had the time in my life there you know
and and when i mean time in my life
at that age i was right where i was
supposed to be
back in in 92 when they constructed the
dream team together
i was just a little kid in hutches texas
watching tv
and i just thought it was cool that they
had basketball in
on in the summer time on regular tv
because you know you couldn't really
watch
tv you had to have cable to take in as
many games as possible and i was just
one of those kids
anything basketball i'm taking it in and
i remember just that time of the dream
team watching them it was just
incredible wait a minute michael jordan
and magic johnson and all these guys on
the same team that doesn't
yeah i was trying to comprehend it the
x-men yeah you know what i mean
and that pretty much sparked the
obsession
and so every olympics i mean i would
watch the olympics
i mean we watch gymnastics we'd watch
track and field we'd watch anything
to do with the olympics and getting to
take part in beijing was quite amazing
and
you know just to be there taking part in
the opening ceremony
but most importantly getting to have the
experience of playing basketball for my
country
and being able to represent the usa and
win a gold medal i mean
that was everything you know that you
have a good bio
just for those who didn't pick up on
this when you can omit the olympic gold
medal
from your bio
just as a side note that doesn't happen
all too
often the reason i brought up the
olympics is because
i had heard i think it was might have
been lebron james
who who mentioned this but that while
other people were killing time
or doing a b and c playing cards you
were
trying to teach yourself spanish
and this is the type of anecdote that
came up over
and over again whether related to
craft beer collection and making craft
beer there are these parallel tracks
and i found that very interesting
because sometimes it's the side notes
that tell a lot of the main story
even though basketball is the most
obvious yeah is that a myth is that true
spanish does that answer the page
probably true yeah
i'm surprised that they would remember
something like that
you know to me that's you know that was
when you had to like have the whole
eighth cd
set oh yeah yeah you you know you had a
separate bag for it yeah you got to have
a whole separate carry-on
i could see that and i'm i forgot all
about that actually but yeah i mean
language was always something that was
just
nagging at me and i just had to do and
godly back in 08 that would mean i had
just started and i was trying to put two
and two together and i thought it was so
cool that rosetta stone had a
eight cd packet that you could take with
you and and download on your computer
and all that that you could buy at an
airport
yes you remember when that was the thing
absolutely yes and i thought that was so
cool cause i'm like yo i got that
but i remember taking it with me i was
always i always had a fascination with
language
always trying to pick it up and and
believe it or not it actually
getting drafted by toronto in the
beginning years
for some reason i wanted i thought i
could learn french like oh yeah i'm
gonna learn french
no problem no problem and i got up there
everybody speaks english
you know and so it's like you gotta
watch
tv and i was trying to watch tv it just
didn't happen and it didn't make any
sense
and so probably a few months after that
i said okay
i need to learn spanish because more
there's more spanish speakers in the
world than there are
french so let's start there and yeah i
started learning spanish and
that was uh before i got a tutor so i
started with rosetta stone and you know
that was okay and then
um i i hired a tutor and then i ended up
making the move to miami eventually
which
it helped me out quite a bit just in
i'm their son you know and um they
really really loved it but just the
culture
that was down in miami it was just
really just a perfect fit
and i don't know what it was i just had
to learn
languages it's just one of those things
that just calls me communicating with
people
talking with people and and really it
was always beneficial because we would
have
teammates i have had three three
teammates from spain
two or three teammates from spain and
you have guys coming from europe and
africa
and south america and stuff like that so
you you want to be able to communicate
efficiently
yeah with them and you know just
learning different languages and stuff
like that it
has helped me quite a bit you can cover
a lot of the globe of spanish
yeah a lot of places absolutely a lot of
places
and it's a good beginning right this is
a good latin base because then you can
be like okay portuguese
italian you can hop around yeah you can
hop around pretty
not easily but it could happen so i
heard you say
the words in
your i don't want to say last speech but
uh when your jersey was put up into the
rafters
so for people who don't know and don't
worry folks if you don't know anything
about basketball
that's me too because i have little
squirrel hands i'm i'm very small
and during the winter is when basketball
was an option i actually did not get
accepted to the jv basketball team
because
as the coach put it i dribbled like a
caveman so i ended up wrestling
that's going to be my excuse for not
knowing much about basketball
but we will we will come back to the
very very very very building blocks of
basketball in a moment but
because this is also not explicitly
mentioned in your bio
could you explain for people how you
came
to retire or how your basketball career
came to an end
and then we're going to fill in the in
between yeah yeah okay so
um you're 13. and it was kind of like uh
not a long drawn-out process but pretty
much what happened is it started with a
pulmonary embolism i ended up having a
pulmonary embolism i had chest pains
back pains all kind of different pains
had a collapse left lung
partially for a while and i was still
playing i chalked it up to
something else happened it wasn't
definitely anything life-threatening
and it definitely wasn't anything that
would end my season let alone my career
but i kept playing
and we eventually you know it got so bad
um i went to the hospital and i had to
end up having to get a surgery
let me see i was in the hospital for you
know close to two weeks it was pretty
much like solitary confinement i didn't
really think about it until it was over
but
i didn't leave that room for you know a
good two weeks
i had two tubes in my chest right here
on my ribs on the side of my ribs
right below my uh chest and i had to
drag that around with me after surgery
for a few days until
you know i got all the the leakage out
that took about
a week and then after that i was able to
recover
was able to come back and play
basketball
and then that next year we found another
clock
and so pretty much when you're in a
situation with with blood clots and
stuff like that if you have a second
blood clot
it's almost like you're radioactive and
so
that pretty much was it it was uh during
all-star weekend in toronto
i was uh reshaping my game i'm a
three-point shooter now i'm actually in
a three-point competition i'm
looking forward to this my career being
revitalized and still being on top of my
game still being an all-star still
performing
at a high elite level we felt that we
had a team good enough to compete for a
championship that year we're second or
third
in the east we're ready to go we're
right there in the um driver's seat
and uh we unfortunately found another
clot it was a blood clot in my lower
extremities
that was pretty much the end of the
season i continued to try to come back
but
it just didn't happen with doctors and
and things like that and
teams and question marks and we found
out that
it's not that much research the research
has been inconclusive about athletes
blood clots and things like that
and you know we we tried and i did try i
gave it the old college try to try to
come back but
it just proved to be too much and i have
a family i have children
and i have to start thinking about that
it's like the easy tough decision to
make
right you know what's right but i just
love basketball so much and
and i just figured this was this was my
time to really prove myself as
for the umpteenth time to be an elite
player in the world and
you know it was just that second act or
third act rather that didn't happen
and was the cause ultimately whether
definitively or just tentatively
concluded to be a
hereditary disease or was it i did test
to see if it was hereditary it's not
i don't have the genetic markers that
would
mean i just have recurring clots when
they said that i was like okay well
great
yeah yeah it just seemed to have come
out of nowhere
especially in a sport where you know
trauma is pretty
you know you're getting leg trauma on a
nightly basis
but this is just something that i had to
move past
eventually and as tough as it was
i had to move on with my life and um you
know eventually
figure out how to move past it and do
something else
we'll likely come back to that at some
point just just psychologically
philosophically
how you've navigated that but yeah
absolutely as promised i want to jump
back to
to lincoln high school and uh we are
going to at some point
we i'm using the royal we i'm not i
don't mean to embarrass my
audience by including you and the
questions i might ask about basketball
they're going to be very very basic
but let me first ask as we kind of segue
into this
i just want to read part of this
paragraph on wikipedia because
i have something related to ask about it
all right so the six foot eleven
teenager we didn't mention that yet
six foot eleven a teenager
helped lincoln high capture and this
again wikipedia so feel free to fact
check anyway class 4a state title is he
delivered 23 points and 17 rebounds to
go along with nine blocks
here's the paragraph that really caught
my attention all right bosh was
subsequently named high school player of
the year by basketball america powerade
player of the year in texas
a first-team all-american by parade
mcdonald's and ea sports second team
all-american by usa today
and slam magazine and it goes on and on
and on and on and on and on and on and
on
and my question is
what was it like for you at that age
to get that amount of visibility
yeah and that amount of i suppose fame i
mean this is
later you'd be much much better known
but at that age i think back to all the
terrible decisions that i made
in high school all the terrible
decisions i continued to make for a long
time
yeah and it was not in any way fueled i
wouldn't have had the opportunities
afforded to someone
with tremendous visibility what was that
like as a student
in high school and was there a moment
when you were like oh wow
okay yeah okay things are going to be
different it's like continuously
happening like that
yeah the thing with me is i was lucky to
find
the thing right that thing that you love
once i found basketball and that's one
of the things that i always encourage
not only the youth but people in general
find
that thing that you love and you know
people can help you get there but only
you know
and only you know that feeling whether
it's sewing knitting architecture
it could be anything but for me i found
basketball pretty quickly
and in my mind
it was all supposed to happen one of the
interesting questions i get
is people ask me what else would you be
doing that's kind of a hard
question to answer because i didn't do
anything else so it was basketball
video games and friends and you know of
course school work
anything outside of that it really
didn't get too much
in in my atmosphere and so with that
said
i was always able to go to practice or
go to the gym
or even play basketball video games or
read the newspaper and see
what the stats are and who's leading the
eastern conference or who's leading the
league in scoring rebounding
and things of that nature i never wanted
to do anything else
basketball was was it i grew up watching
michael jordan and kobe bryant
and of course all the other stars too
but those two guys in particular
they were always winning you know as
soon as i found out what basketball was
i knew who magic johnson you know was
and huge success in the 80s five
championships
and then michael jordan is there i
watched him pretty much
win six live and then kobe bryant comes
along and
he was the dude that made it real
because he was a teenager
doing things that jordan did so once
that started happening
it became more obsessive are you
familiar with slam magazine
i'm not but i can imagine the subject
matter
possibly so you know slam magazine was
pretty much like
the basketball magazine and so that was
like the internet you know so
you go get your slam magazine and i
started putting these posters
on my wall of kevin garnett tim duncan
and
kobe bryant michael jordan all these
guys and just
obsessively following the game but they
would also
put in these articles with the high
school talent
it was all basketball high school
college and pros and so for me
with all the content i consumed whether
it was movies
whether it was watching slam magazine
these things were supposed to happen
so when they started happening for me it
was more like
okay cool i was still in my bubble
did you feel in a way because of this
extreme focus on basketball
that you had identified it as like the
path your path
yeah that these things were sort of i
don't want to say ordained to happen but
you were like
if i am in fact destined to be on this
path
like these are the following markers
along that path
and therefore when you show up yourself
and slam magazine you're like
yeah so mr slam like okay as it was
written
full disclosure i didn't like the slam
article that they made of me
it's like i finally got my half page and
i'm like that's the photo they chose
[Laughter]
but you know yeah it was kind of those
markers you know getting those markers
pretty much from the ninth grade on and
one of the things that was always
interesting nobody fun fact in our
yearbook i wasn't
chosen because we had another we had
other good players as well i wasn't
chosen most likely to be in the nba
so i was never like yeah chris just like
you were reading off
yeah you're saying usa second team is
still like
wins a little bit they messed that one
up it's okay usa today
but with that said that was just always
my mentality i was not not written off
but
in my mind it was always how it was
supposed to happen and i started growing
and then
i guess once that notoriety came for me
it was like okay yeah about time yeah
but
once i started getting that notoriety i
wanted to get in the gym more
because it was working you know so from
ninth grade pretty much
on every time i saw success or if i was
in the paper
or if the coach told me good job or
something like that
i wanted more it was always an emphasis
on doing more work
you know doing more work and you're like
the recipe works
let's crank out some more pizza pies
with that
it's going pretty good let's uh yeah
let's make something out of this and and
you know
one of the interesting things and
probably one of the things that lit a
fire under me
was my dad you know we weren't we
weren't the poorest
kids i would describe my upbringing as
lower middle class
but he sat me down or we would drive all
the time and ride everywhere and he told
me one day like i was like 12 he said
hey man
i can't pay for college so uh basketball
you love basketball that's awesome you
can get a scholarship playing basketball
and that's great because i can't pay for
college he kept saying i can't pay for
college
and i thought that was fascinating that
you could actually wow you could go to
college and play basketball okay
and i started you know that began a
session with schools and
mascots and learning the colors on top
of all the stats and stuff
you know so once i really started
getting into it i mean
it just grew and grew and grew and as it
grew
so did the notoriety so let's talk about
making those pizza pies
the recipe that was working i want to
try to tease apart some
some pieces of that so you mentioned a
name
kevin garnett if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
were there any players you
watched and decided to emulate i had
read
that kg was one such player i don't know
if that's true you can't believe
everything you read on the internet
of course so you can confirm or you can
confirm or deny but were there players
who you watched early on in your
development as a player
or as a player who you decided to
emulate for one reason or another
oh yeah kevin garnett and tim duncan all
right more so kg
but tim duncan of course too because he
was right down the street and
his nickname was the big fundamentals
and every coach loved the way he played
the game
so i would play the power forward which
is you know it's kind of a dying
position now but it was called the four
and it was cool to be a four
like oh man early 2000s late 90s to be a
four man it was awesome
and so it was just kind of looking for
guys that looked like me
looked like you in terms of physical
physical stature
or lack thereof but you know it's kind
of
you know growing up playing the game
when you're skinny when you're
mass hasn't caught up with your bones
yeah
it's kind of you know people kind of be
like ah you know you hear all the skinny
jokes
and you need to eat something and lift
some weights and like i am lifting
weights
you know but it was always this
preconceived notion
or this stigma that you had to have size
to play down low and once i saw kg play
when you say down low what do you mean
closer to the rim i see
you know now the game is more spread
it's more around the three-point line
in the game back then was more people in
the paint
so that's how the game was played closer
to the basket a lot more
physicality a lot of banging around
you know and i'm sure a lot of people
were worried for me
but you know once i saw kevin it was one
in highlight in particular
long and skinny he was a what an
all-star when he was 19
20 years old he came straight out of
high school in 96
no 95 and
he was long and skinny like me and one
of the things kind of you were
joking and saying how your coach said
you handled the ball like a caveman
he could handle the ball yeah that was
kind of like a new thing
not new all the way but old school
coaches would tell me
if you're tall don't dribble that was a
part of the game don't put the ball on
the floor
i saw him put the ball on the floor and
rebound and block
shots and play defense and he had this
intensity
and tenacity to him the way he played
the game it was just infectious and
and you know i was like yo i want to do
that
and so i would imagine going to the park
and imagine these moves and
imagine myself doing you know with
visualize every day man and
once i saw that it was over and i mean
he was cool too he had to
have the swag the young guy swag back
then had to
had to look and you know had the off
court look in the slam and
it was just amazing to me and i just
wanted that's all i wanted to do i
wanted to be
hope that's what i wanted to be right
there kg
not only tall ball handling skills and a
lot of people don't know this a lot of
people don't know this but that was
actually my nickname i never i haven't
told anybody that was my they called me
kg in high school in summer league like
kg that's how bad
i wanted to you know emulate his game
and make it to the nba
people were calling me kg all right so
so this is
this is the intended segue into all
sorts of terminology that i'm going to
need your help with i don't know but
let's
let's uh let's talk about tim duncan
just for a second because
the big fundamentals the big
fundamentals man that's a cool name
now what did the coaches like about his
playing style you said they all loved
his playing style
what what were the ingredients that they
loved about his playing style he had
that stoic demeanor
he was never just he brought the
intensity and he played hard but it
wasn't anything extra
wasn't flashy the opposite of flashy
but like we were speaking of playing
down low
closer to the basket his moves that he
used were very basic
but devastating sometimes when you're
dealing with younger players
that are good at the game the simplicity
can get to them
so they want to show that they're good
by doing something fancy
and then usually you're messing it up
right but
tim he made his career off of
establishing position
basic stuff establishing position
getting your move
technique you know playing within the
system and he was unstoppable
i mean he was he was mvp of the league
and perennial all-star you know and
the best for man to ever play the game
you have to put him in that same context
if you're trying to be successful
and by playing within the system do you
mean within a coach's
prescribed system like a set number of
plays like
basketball is a fast moving game and it
can look like
guys are just out there or girls are
just out there just
running around and not really doing much
but there is
a method to the madness method to the
madness you're supposed to be in a
certain position even if it's within the
flow
of a game so you know when i say system
that's what i mean by that if he was at
the top
he knew exactly what to do if he's down
low
he knew exactly what to do and
that added on top of the talent yeah
they could have given it to him and say
okay bring us home
big fella and that would have worked but
he
added so much longevity on his career by
playing within the system in my opinion
and
and i mean that made it more dangerous
because you have to worry about
all of these other things happening yeah
if you're defending him
it's for other people out there that you
have to worry about but then he's
hitting you on your body down low yeah
getting the ball and he was incredibly
strong too
okay so this this is this is fun for me
as a basketball
illiterate to begin to sort of piece
this together in my own mind
because you have the big fundamentals
who's playing with within the system not
in a
negative sense but meaning he he
understands how to play with
and synergize with the other elements on
the team absolutely
he is not doing anything fancy for
fancy's sake
right so as we were talking about before
we started recording how like morgan
spurlock once told me like once you get
fancy fancy gets broken right like
that's a good one
and that's a good one and fancy can work
but you better have the fundamentals
first right so he's
devastating within the system which is a
possibility and then you have
kg kevin garnett who is in some ways
violating the expectations of him not
because it's impossible to do so just
because there isn't much historic
president for somebody his size also
having the dexterity to be a
right to handle the ball really well
especially in the mid 90s right which
later you were you would also receive
that compliment
quite a lot and i want to go to power
forward
and is it four man is that right a four
all right
four this is the four this is where i'm
really gonna embarrass myself here we go
so i'm gonna make a confession i was
reading through the research i was
reading about your bio i was watching
videos and i thought to myself
this might as well be in greek i can't
i can't even begin to imagine what these
terms
mean half of them so i went to this
these people are going to love this so i
went to wikipedia and i looked up
basketball
yeah i was like i was like let's just
start there
and and just to be clear like i i do
watch basketball i appreciate i mean i
clearly don't follow it very well but i
can appreciate the athleticism i
understand what a three-point shot is
i understand what a jump shot is layup
slam dunk etc some of some of these
terms
i actually do know but i realized that i
did not know
the positions whatsoever and so i just
want to read something and then we can
dive in
so this is from the wikipedia entry on
basketball folks
yes feel free to laugh all right so
first of all if you didn't know this
five players on each side
it turns out all right so the five
players on each side fall into five
playing positions the tallest player is
usually the center
second tallest and strongest the power
forward a slightly shorter but more
agile player is the small forward and
the shortest players or the best ball
handlers are the shooting guard and the
point guard
who implement the coach's game plan by
managing the execution of offense and
defensive plays
in parentheses player positioning
informally players may play three on
three two on two
one-on-one and then i'll just add this
because i was like what really
invented in in 1891 by canadian american
gym teacher james nyesmith or naismith
perhaps
naysmith in springfield massachusetts
united states
basketball has evolved to become one of
the world's most popular and widely used
sports so number one
1891 not that long ago not that long ago
that's crazy yeah that is insane
that is just that's like wheels on
luggage where you're like really it took
us that long
wow and they started with a peach basket
did you get to that point so back in the
day
when they made the game they had to have
something to do in the wintertime
in massachusetts so they put the peach
basket up there
and when you make a basket they had to
get a ladder to climb up and take it out
it wasn't until later that they cut a
hole in the peach basket
climbing up and getting it out not as
compelling for television yeah yeah
it's like oh good okay let me go hold on
hold on give me a few minutes no the
game will be two to three or something
like that you know
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs small business owners have
always shown an incredible ability to
adapt and innovate
this past year has certainly highlighted
many examples
now another way you can adapt and
innovate in 2021 is by
finding the right people to help you
grow your business
linkedin jobs makes it possible for you
to do exactly that
get started by posting your job for free
to reach linkedin's network of more than
740
million professionals fill out targeted
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation you're looking for
then with simple filtering and
management tools you can easily review
rate and home in on your top candidates
linkedin jobs
can help you find the right person to
help you grow your business and your
first
job post is free so just visit
linkedin.com
tim to learn more again that's
linkedin.com
tim to post your first job for free
terms and conditions
do apply
so i just want to kind of run through
this again and then get your commentary
just as to
how to think about the game now also
understanding the game is not static
right and how the game is played changes
especially now especially now so we can
take these rules and then we're about to
break them okay
all right so not to say you have to
comment on what i just read because
obviously you're much more qualified
than the
37 people who put that together how
should we think about
the positions of basketball like if i
were an alien
which might as well be the case yeah and
i'm looking at this i understand
what i said i understand you're like all
right how are the jobs
and responsibilities separated out here
how should we think about that
well you know with those positions with
all those positions with that said
it's been totally yeah and each of those
positions
is numbered therefore yeah power forward
one the two that's like when you get
into it like oh yeah i play the two
that's when you're super cool yeah you
got it
like i'm at the five with the short hand
yeah i'm at the five all right one
two three you know you have your
positions but with that said
the game has changed so you have one
through five the one is the point guard
the two is the shooting guard three
small forward four power forward
and the five is the center what has
happened in the last few years is that
it's become more of a spread game
because mathematically
people that do data eventually said hey
let's shoot more threes
because these shots we don't like these
shots
we like these shots that's interesting
at the floor so is there
so is the reason sorry to interrupt but
i'm gonna do it a lot um
so the is the reason that the
three-point shot has become more and
more prominent that was driven by kind
of like the saber metrics equivalent
it came from the data wonks not from the
players side there were some players
in particular me and shane battier we
would talk about my good friend shane
battier we played together in uh miami
during the championship years
we would talk about this we had just got
him he had played his career in houston
and memphis in houston
it's a guy by the name of daryl moore
he's the president for the sixers
in philadelphia right now big stat guy
love stats
i mean a number cruncher and so
they had a certain team and it was a
whole culture
of stat driven guys shane came from that
and so that's where we would kind of
talk and we would talk about threes and
contested twos
and just different shots so if you're
within the three-point line right
or a contested shot is if you're
shooting and i just put my hand up
trying to defend you
right trying to deny you from actually
putting
two or three points up and so it it
turns you're pretty good at denying
other people
for sure yeah you know i've seen that
link
i have seen this so like it came to be
that
uh the worst shot in basketball is a
contested two
15 to 18 19 20 feet away from the god
just statistically when they look at
like the statistically
terrible you know and so people took
that information
and said okay hey we need to play faster
we need more points
big fella you need to dribble so now
it's
you want everybody interesting because
all of a sudden all the things
we're not supposed to do is everybody
should do it you know and it's like wow
you play the game everybody should be
able to do the basic fundamentals
but now it's opened up to where now you
have guys
like um you know nicola yokic probably
never heard of him he's a big man
that plays in denver one of the best
players in the league he's a five man
but he handles the ball you know which
is a five man again
the center okay thank you so to confuse
you more yes please now you have a thing
called the point
center okay that's if your big fella can
bring it down
but the evolution of the game you've had
guys like you know magic johnson then
lebron
james comes and he's very tall but he
can handle the ball and you have ben
simmons giannis antetokounmpo
these guys who are very tall
seven feet six eight to seven feet who
back in the day
you could say okay hey you're a four or
a center or something else
they've totally transformed the game
because they're the guys bringing it up
the floor
and they're getting the team into
offense so they're doing the job of the
point guard
so now it's more of uh the term
positionless
when we were playing when i was playing
it's crazy to say the last decade
early in the 2010s that became kind of
one of our words
to say positionless disruption that's
the word i'm looking for
so you know basketball has been
disrupted what we thought
was the game has been cracked open and
now it's just become
not just it's become a faster pace
longer uh
shots more athleticism and um not so
much
the cookie cutter approach to where
someone should be
on the court because of their size or
lack of size
you know it makes me wonder about
adaptability
and the adaptability of not just some
players
and i'm sure there's also just a
selection bias that changes
with respect to who who is drafted and
how
and just the the entire feeder system
into the nba
but also coaches even more so coaches
like if their entire
career has been predicated on a system
of a certain type
i mean i'm not asking you to name names
but have you seen certain coaches who've
been
really able to adapt to this new style
of playing others who are like
i don't know i don't get it well the
ones who say i don't know i don't get it
they don't have jobs
right yeah and they get weeded out
quickly
one of the guys uh of course you know my
ex-coaching
uh eric spoelstra he i remember him he
was having the vision
of having that positionless type of
basketball and that faster pace
which i didn't like at the time because
that would mean i would have to play the
center
as opposed of the power forward and i
didn't want to do that
but just taking advantage of the speed
why didn't you want to do that because i
was banging up against guys
uh bigger than me so usually in the nba
my playing weight was about 235
240. if i'm playing the five i'm banging
with guys
that are 280 270 and on a weekly
nor nightly instances uh man it gets
brutal but you know it did work
as far as you know using the speed to
get around
the bigger defenders so essentially
playing
i guess if you were a fighter going to
class
up in weight yep because you're quicker
you can
you know hit them more yeah yeah that
was pretty much the philosophy
one of the other guys who have done i
think have done a great job is uh
greg popovich he's uh in san antonio
he's done a wonderful job because they
run the same place
yeah they just extend them oh
interesting okay could you could you
expand on that because i remember yeah
watching the last dance
and watching this segment on the the
spurs
yeah and sort of there i don't want to
say playbook but sort of systematic
approach
and some of the debate around that right
because their other players are like
that's not fun to watch
right like they should do a b and c
instead because it beats you
it's not fun to watch your team getting
beat you know
so can you expand on what you mean by
that so they have the same
fundamental system but they expanded it
so it's kind of um the best analogy i
could put to it is um
you know i don't want to expose their
system but everybody knows their system
it's
predicated and i might i might be saying
this wrong but then but it's two
two plays that are the base in their
system weak and strong
i can't remember which side of the court
if you're on this side of the court this
week on another side of the court is
strong
but that's their base of the offense
like i was saying earlier the game a few
years ago was being
played closer to the rim there was
nowhere to go there's no space
even if you want to get your best player
attacking into the paint
if there's eight other people in there
it makes it a little more difficult
traffic jam
traffic jam so you can take those same
plays in basketball and just
tell your players hey all these things
from the heat days are gonna come into
my head but
pace and space i can't believe i'm
saying that i like it
but that's what you know the space was
very particular because you want to be
able to see what's going on and to
attack the rim
get closer to the rim for easy buckets
well all you have to do is
hey if you're in the paint i want you to
get out there we're going to run the
same place but
as opposed to being six feet away from
the basket
get 16. i need you in this 12 to 16 area
feet right here because usually bigs
they wanted to keep them we call them
bigs the fours and the fives bigs
we want to keep you as close to the
basket as possible but that was clogging
it up for the smaller guys to be able to
attack
yeah so you would tell to be able to
they want to keep their bigs close to
the basket not to state the obvious but
so that you can
receive a pass jump up done be tall
rebound
right do all the things yeah the tall
things do all the things that tall
people do
yeah well if you spread the court that
makes it a little tougher to guard
it takes bodies away from the painted
area you know that area
yeah where the paint yeah that's what we
call it harden the paint
hard in the paint if people have
wondered what that term
is my girlfriend told me i was like what
oh my god i never knew that it's going
hard in the paint yeah
you can have the same type of offense
which is nobody is reinventing the wheel
here
but what's happened is the the game has
become faster
and more spread so that you know more
offensive
opportunities can happen so you have
preemptively developed ball handling
skills which lo and behold
now are this huge asset yeah as the game
evolves
but you get put into center
where you're basically running into
freight trains mm-hmm uh-oh
it was a part of my whole career it was
happening i'm not saying a bad thing
yeah but
but initially you're like this is i
don't want to do this
now again based on just the the homework
that i've done i mean you you seem to be
also
very very well known as a rebounder
and one of the questions that comes to
mind for me is
if suddenly the bigs is that the term
are expanded out further away from the
basket does that
not make it harder for you to utilize
one of your superpowers
with well in a ways there there are
certain things that
do get taken away in our case it was a
little easier to make that sacrifice
because we had
dwayne and wade and lebron so
if it's saying hey chris we need you to
get out the paint and spread the floor
yeah your offensive rebounding
opportunities are gonna
sink quite a bit but it's better
if we get those guys attacking yep so
you need to be out here
and one of the things that kind of
developed was having a
more sound defenses okay instead of
crashing the boards just get back
because you know the defense especially
you know if the defense gets the rebound
now they're on offense
if they're running if they're a fast
team you want to
mitigate their opportunities for easy
baskets
so you know and that's that can be a
stat too which i'm pretty sure we uh
we dug up that we did dig up that stat
what's the percentage of you getting an
offensive rebound
versus not getting a stop because of
that it's a question question for you on
the stats and maybe this is getting
too too nerdy but do all the teams have
equal access to data and it's just a
matter of analyzing it
more effectively yeah oh we can go on
nba.com and get all the stats right now
wow so that's hard like everybody has
it's an open book right it's an open it
wasn't like that before
and the way you crunch those numbers is
not an open book
so everybody gets the data but that's
all it is it's just data it's just
telling you what happened
the last game or over the course of the
game it's on the teams to kind of take
that and utilize it
if they want to now some people do
overdo it in my opinion you can kind of
get some people like yeah you know
it's the way we want to play okay got to
tie your shoes with the left hand first
but they're still you know in my you
know in my case it's still some
fundamentals to the game that
you know you can't really get around you
mentioned uh
eric spoelstra if i'm getting the
pronunciation right our mutual friend
ryan holiday had given me a bullet which
was
uh related to books that eric had given
you what books did he give you
they come to mind he would give books
every christmas to the team
so there were quite a few quite a few
and i read all of them i was probably
the only dude to read all of them
it was even kind of funny because one
time we were cleaning out their lockers
and our lockers and said
you know some i won't name who but
somebody grabbed the book from there
like oh man
spoke thanks for this christmas gift is
this in june we're
blowing dust off of it you know
but when we first met i had just signed
to miami
and i was always reading i was always
been an avid reader
since i was a kid and i just fell into
reading books i would always read books
especially on the road
before naps before games that was my
thing
and he knew that about me he had heard
that about me him being a
good coach said hey i'mma get him this
book i heard he's a reader
he got me outliers by gladwell
and i said okay you know he gave it to
me and i took it oh that's cool i read
that book
and he was he he just kind of looked at
me like what
and then ever since then he would i
guess i hope that i pushed him to do
more research
in his book buying but yeah he would he
would get us uh books
every christmas were there any that
stood out to you one in particular was
grit because he used that term
all the time the author slipping my name
duckworth angela duckworth
and you know he got us that book and he
would always use these phrases
and so grit was a huge huge huge word
that he used that i'm sure he still uses
to this day
but that book in particular he bought
for the team and i read that one i do
remember that one and it's another one
that's slipping my mind but i remember
specifically
we were having a conversation and it
wasn't an easy conversation
usually when you're a coach you're
having tough conversations 24 7 with
your players because everybody wants the
ball
i was having one of those conversations
like hey give me the ball you know
and um it was one chapter in particular
that was
saying push versus pull some people you
have to push
some people you have to pull another
chapter that
said you have to have an open mindset or
a closed mindset you don't want to close
mindset you want an open mindset the
book will come to me in a minute
i had to like you know challenge him on
having an open mindset
[Music]
hey give me the ball yeah have an open
mindset coach you know
remember that book you gave me and i
always
loved that one because is the book that
he gave us and i had to use it you know
to kind of
try to get my way
but i always i want to say it's good to
great but that's probably not the one
but those uh good to great is one of
them those books in particular
i mean like i say throughout the whole
time throughout the whole stint
in miami you know he gifted us books and
i'm pretty sure
he gifted us the obstacle is the way
yeah i want to say he did
i'm pretty pretty sure but you know i
just thought it was fascinating just
a coach taking the time to think of his
teammates and give them
food for thought something to think
about and i always enjoyed that and i
would read it and i felt like
i was getting inside his mind and the
minds of others
reading these passages and kind of
taking you know and interpreting it
for myself right before the game you
know it was always great
wow so you would read right before right
before playing oh yeah
really i would uh it was uh funny pat
riley he told me he's like you like
kareem
kareem abdul-jabbar he would sit there
and read the whole time
and a couple of my young players when i
was the old grizzled vet
they they told me like i would just sit
there reading and you know i'm oblivious
to this stuff i'm just getting my mind
right you know
this was i read because this was my
relaxing time because this is about to
get hectic yeah so you're not reading
like black hawk down you're reading
maybe maybe i might yeah but if i'm
reading black hawk down it's the
playoffs
[Laughter]
you know it's winning time but you know
i always tried to give myself that peace
of mind it was like
i felt like it was my time and granted
we're in the locker room there's media
everywhere
and people it's like the buzz of an nba
game about to start
and i would sit there and they told me
man when you close that book it's like
all right he's ready let's go
yeah yeah i would read and all the way
up until coast
is about to start talking it's like all
right cool let's uh let's go and do it
are there any books that you've reread
multiple times
that come to mind i mean or was it
always a new book that you would read
i always read a new book but the book
that i read all the time which you uh i
know that you're uh
a connoisseur of japanese culture is uh
the way and the power
you heard of that book no so it's a book
called the way in the power
um i had a buddy of mine who was a
kenpo black belt many times over
he gifted me that book it pretty much
was breaking down the way of the samurai
and it was two books into one the way
and the power
strategies the powers more so like
strategies for a master
distancing confusion how to handle
conflict
things like that the way is more so
shaping the body and shaping the mind to
become a samurai so the exercises that
one has to do
to get to the point to start mastery
before you can even think about it you
know you need to be here you know
one of the passages said you have to
look successful you want to be able to
look good so i took all these principles
and applied them to basketball so what
they meant by looking good was saying
hey
shirt tucked in regulation everything is
good to go
my shoes are tied i don't have to worry
about them because i have this
knot that they won't come loose so i'm
not worried about my shoes while i'm
playing
it also says you know exercise must be
vigorous
people need to tell so you have that
strong spirit you know when you're
showing up before you even play
my muscle definition is good i'm ready
to play
because we've been working hard we want
to
feel that you know it's uh feeling the
spirit before you even start playing the
game working on your key
things like that huh yeah the way in the
power the way in the power i think you'd
enjoy it cool check that out cool
yeah and it's got japanese you know i'm
into it they don't translate
the words so for instance one of the
principles is called motion
that really resonates no mind no mind
so you attack with no mind i don't think
about everything we've done all the
studying
i filled myself with my opponent huh and
i'm
attacking with no mind that's because
i've done all the training
that is super cool that's oh you know
that that's a mission
yes so you read that and be like oh yeah
that's cool
yeah this this character
shin which is also kokoro yeah uh is
is also used for heart but it's it's
like spirit heart and mind all wrapped
into once culturally
super interesting yeah very fast and i
mean they yeah they don't change they do
not
translate because some of them have no
translation right yeah so
they have the like motion for instance
it's called motion then they do english
but yeah
the title the principle is is all
japanese
so you mentioned the not having the
right knots you're not worried about
your shoes
i might be misattributing this i don't
think i am but even though i know very
little about most sports
i'm fascinated by consistent
top performers because it's like once
you're lucky twice you're good
like for a decade okay yeah
there there is some method and
i recall reading this story about john
wooden
famed i guess ucla
and i recall reading a story i'm sure
i'm gonna get the details wrong
but when he would meet a bunch of new
players
sit down and he'd walk them through ty
in their shoes and
and they'd be like why does this matter
like little things matter because if you
mess this up
you're going to get irritated and you're
going to get a blister and then you're
not going to be able to move properly
and that's going to cost you points and
that's going to cost you the game
and i was like oh so good
so good pyramid of success pyramid of
success
pyramid of success by john wooden you
can check that one out
that pretty much describes that so he
had a pyramid
of success and that's one of the uh
myths or stories or whatever they pretty
much owned
the 60s and 70s you know ucla basketball
they built it to what it is you know
historically
today and not only did he get the best
players and great players
abdul jabbar being one of them he had
the best teams
and coming in to play for a great coach
like that it's like okay first day of
practice
oh i can't wait what are we gonna do and
he's showing them
how to put on their socks and shoes you
know
practically and perfectly and that was
the first day of practice
so you know just i'm just imagining the
faces
could you imagine that like we bout to
oh what what offense are we gonna run
this is going to be the best
and you know which and and if you agree
there's an actual pyramid that he built
and constructed and tying shoes and
socks was at the very bottom of the
pyramid of success so and then he do
this every year
every year that would be the first thing
that they would go over
and then they would build on top of that
and you know he was
testing and tracking
and keeping notes it's not accidental
that that ended up at the bottom of the
pyramid of course
of course but that makes sense right
yeah if you get a blister you know
especially back in those days
everybody's playing in chuck taylor's
that's important yeah that's important
man you gotta hey let's this is
important stuff and
you know like i was alluding to earlier
that's the challenge with younger
players right they want to go right to
being
the master and doing the things that you
know you think that a master is supposed
to be doing when
we need to do this first the basic basic
fundamentals
that way when it's winning time we can
be healthy
it's kind of like many sayings out there
but you have a the bit and the horse in
the shoe if that nail isn't right then
the horse
you know it's all these catastrophic
events that could possibly follow if
this one basic thing is not
correct you've spent a lot of time as a
leader
with other leaders whether players
iconic players coaches
whole broad spectrum are there any
particular
lessons or stories related to leadership
that stick out to you
things you saw or absorbed from from
anyone in particular
my high school coach leonard bishop he
talked to me one time
and as much as i became
more social later in life this is me at
17 years old
6 11. all the accolades
are possible and they can possibly come
he called me in his office and he told
me
you don't have to be loud to be a leader
you can lead by example
and you know we always hear the thing
lead by example right you hear that all
the time but what does that even mean
right and he told me he explained it to
me he said you know
you can lead by
putting your work in being on time
being dressed and ready to go when it's
time to practice
staying after practice your teammates
are watching
you all the time so if you do these
things and lead by example
never giving up never quitting playing
hard these are the things that could be
infectious you don't have to be the guy
given to win one for the gipper speech
you can go out there
and you can be yourself and that was so
comforting to me
i remember that conversation we were
having in his office and i said wow okay
that gave me so much more confidence
because i could be myself
because on the court i'm gonna yell and
scream and do all that stuff all day i'm
not
i wasn't always the player to always
talk during the game at that age but if
it's getting hype and screaming and
yelling i was basketball was always my
release to do that
it was comforting to know i could be
myself and still
bring the leadership qualities
to that team and you know that always
stuck with me
what are some of the things that people
don't know or don't
see that you think are important about
some of the the the big names you spent
time around whether that
you can take your pick could be anybody
it could be
could be a player could be a coach could
be an owner it could be anyone at all
somebody not on that list because people
see you on tv
yeah maybe they've followed you for a
long time and they maybe they think they
know
what makes you you and they might have a
few things right but they probably have
a whole lot of things wrong
and uh that would also i assume be true
for
many of these big names that you've
spent time around are there any
particular
ingredients or special aspects of
some of these folks that come to mind
that you think are maybe
less appreciated or less obvious to
people one
being human humanizing the people that
can kind of get lost in translation when
you're on tv
so remembering that there's a human
element these are people with families
and
feelings and emotions and on top of that
i think the work that's
that that is being put in to anybody
who's elite at their craft or
even professional with their craft i
mean
it's in a ridiculous amount of work
that's put in to even
be in the league right you know and
right let alone on the short list of
people
and even on the shortlist man they're
working hard you know and um
i don't know like the the first thing
that came to mind when you said that
was like you ever you well i was about
to say you ever watch a basketball game
but
well i haven't watched basketball i have
you have watched basketball so have you
ever
watched it's not saying i understood all
the finer details yeah so have you ever
watched it when they say okay they've
got two days off into their next game
yes
that is not true you're right right not
true
practice treatment appearances
the professional aspect that it takes to
be able
to perform because usually people just
see you on tv
and they see you doing your thing okay
two days off no we do not have two days
off
there are no such thing as weekends if
there's a weekend maybe we play at eight
o'clock as opposed to
7 30 like usual that was the only cursor
for me that let me know it was the
weekend
so just trying to remember and and you
know it's really for all people
who who are good at what they do if you
admire that person remember that there's
a human element that's a human
they're probably going through it or
maybe not or
just whatever comes with life
they're dealing with it and the
tremendous amount of work and focus that
it takes to be able to do that
you know to be able to to say hey i'm i
need to put this to the side to be able
to perform
it's happened many times in my career
you know you go to funerals
you have things you have to fight
through and then you have to play
and you're still expected to win you
know so
just remembering those those things just
remembering that when you're watching
your favorite player or your favorite
author
or favorite engineer whatever that is
the tremendous amount of work and
dedication that it takes to get to that
level
that's what i would like people to to
really remember and understand
i have watched maybe not not enough
basketball but i have watched basketball
and in fact at one point not to say i
ever got particularly good at it but
when i was working on
a book called the four hour chef which
is very confusingly actually about
accelerated learning
which might explain why there's so much
confusion on the part of readers also
but there's a section looking at free
throws
in basketball okay and so i actually
practiced quite a bit with the help of
a few people sort of technicians who are
trying to help me understand basic
principles yeah
and part of the reason for that is that
i have been
just dazzled by
say three-point shots because
as a someone built like a small
flintstones character
myself right i watch people who are
jumping over the rim
and performing these incredible feats of
athleticism i'm like well
i can't even imagine myself doing that
like the physics are just not there
right my bones never caught up with my
mask right
it's the problem it's the other way
around and plus my vertical jumps like
somewhere between half an inch and an
inch
at best so so those are things i just
can't even imagine myself
doing and i think people might be i'm
not saying that
this is everyone but people might be
inclined to say well he's 611.
right so of course he can slam a
basketball but
it's a lot harder to use that
justification when it's a three-point
shot
right it's like no actually actually
like you
short guy yeah tim that's you i'm
talking to you like you should
technically
like you have the physical capability of
doing that so i would just love to hear
and this might be getting too into the
weeds but how you improved
your three-point shots because
it's not just repetition in the sense
like you can make the same mistake
over and over and over again and i've
read about
you doing video review watching games
six to eight times
and so on so i i know that you are
methodical about reviewing your own
performance but how did you improve
something like a three-point shot
i didn't start shooting threes
consistently
until about my third year in miami
second or third year in miami i shot
them
in toronto a little bit but like i said
it still wasn't
we were talking about the game earlier
it wasn't that widely accepted
in the game big men shooting threes
handful of them
now you have a handful that don't we got
to miami
and you know my position or my
responsibilities changed
so i wasn't getting the ball closer to
the basket anymore that was my job in
toronto to get the ball as close to the
best as possible
that's where we functioned i was pretty
good at it
and then the team would go from there
and we would distribute and kind of base
our game off of
i guess my success or lack of success
down low i was telling you earlier that
in miami i had to
get out the way yeah that was my
sacrifice in particular
with that team so that lebron and dee
could penetrate and get into the paint
and
do what they're best in the world at
doing as we continue to play
i had coach when me and shane battier we
would talk all the time about it but
then i had to you know
have discussions with coaches as well
and somebody said something one day said
hey man
just take a step back take one step back
shoot the same shot
but just take a step back because i was
always an avid worker
on my jump shot i was pretty good i was
lethal from mid-range that was my thing
i always worked on it and worked on it
so it's the hundreds of thousands or
millions of reps
that i have shooting the ball i know i
have a touch
anyway it was just extending the range
so it's kind of um one of those things
that if you're good short range in
mid-range hell
if you practice your long range you can
be pretty good too but
getting those fundamentals of the you
know the shooting motion the arm
snapping your wrists following through
balance
all these different fundamentals that
you learn and what goes into a great
shooter
going and seeking that advice learning
from other shooters
always kind of taking in information
but relying on my own information i
think you have to have a good foundation
in what you've done already
by yourself even if it's in the weeds or
in the dark and then
you have hopefully someone that can
refine what you already have or
say something to you to say hey man take
a step back
you can shoot threes and then i started
shooting threes and then as i became
more consistent
you know i found more success and it's
funny to watch the game now because i'm
like man i could still be playing you
know
in 37 i saw myself playing into my you
know 37
38 and i started practicing more threes
because i saw where the game was going i
said okay
yeah they're shooting there's more
threes me and shane have talked about
this
three is more than two okay i'm gonna
start shooting more threes and that in
my last year in the league i
had a higher frequency of three-point
shots and and you know i was seeing some
success so that was exciting
but that was like the part of my career
that i never really got to crack open
yeah yeah with three pointers when
you're watching other players
make three-point shots are their styles
dramatically different or are the good
three-point shooters do they all have
the same ingredients i think there's the
same ingredients i mean you're always
gonna get different flavors
but um it's the same ingredients uh to
me
it's always follow through one fluid
motion and good balance
if you have those things you can shoot
the ball and i always it's kind of funny
you
learning to shoot free throws i would
always tell people i give my friends
pointers
so i have a few buddies that you know
they're producers and songwriters they
always play
yeah in reckless games i won't give away
your sauce dude don't worry i won't
give away your position but i would uh i
just give them like pointers and say
you know like hey man can you help me
with my shot and i just look at them
shoot a couple times and
give them corrections and then they see
instant success you know but that's just
you know elbow in
follow through one fluid motion boom
you have a better you just wanted to go
straight
[Laughter]
and and this you know you can get super
deep into a trajectory
and all that stuff but that's when you
see it's good to get into the
fundamentals
of where the ball is supposed to go and
how you're supposed to hold it
but one of the things that we always do
is just start with one hand shooting
yeah i don't know if they had you doing
that right under the basket just
all day get a lot of repetitions in that
build that muscle memory
and then you can start stepping back as
you get better
yeah the the thing that kind of blew my
mind also which i hadn't thought about
at all because why would i i hadn't had
any exposure
was i was just missing miss and missing
i was like oh for you know
20. even at a close distance one coach
i'm blanking on his name i want to say
it's rick torbett but
he did an eye dominance test
and he's like oh you're right-handed but
you're left eye dominant he's like yeah
shift it like an inch over and then the
whole thing changed i was like
wow wow that's a thing
okay that's pretty good and uh well
maybe someday i'll i'll pick up a
basketball again and
have to confiscate all phones and
cameras first
so be critical to myself close your
right eye shoot it
so what did it feel like going from and
why did you go from
toronto to miami yeah right because like
you were
king of the hill yeah it was mr canada
yeah
mr canada yeah you know it was a it was
a tough decision
i loved toronto and toronto loved me
and it was great just to be able to
compete
and put a city or country on your back
and just hope for the best
and just go out there and work hard
every day and you know i just felt you
know like a pillar of the community
i wanted to do it so bad for toronto
you eventually get to a point in your
career where you have to make a choice
and i went to
you know i talked to many people it was
a dilemma
i didn't know what to do and if you're
familiar with popular culture
or maybe not that year in in 2010
there was a i was like the first mega
free agent
everybody who's free agency was about
eight or nine free agents that's like
okay they're the
best eight or nine guys in the world
right now
they're ready to go things can and will
dramatically change
that was the atmosphere that was coming
and i knew that was coming
and i had tried everything i tried
everything in toronto i tried
to recruit i tried to push myself push
my team and
and you know we weren't even scratching
the surface and one of the tough things
dealing with it is seeing the early
success of my peers
i wanted to win i've always wanted to
win
and i've always wanted to put in the
work to be able to do that
and compete and hopefully gain glory in
that way
i talked to a lot of older players
and um about what to do about what to do
and uh older gentlemen as well and the
thing that i
kept hearing was that you want to play
on the stage man
it's about going forward it's about
competing for a championship
you want to play on that stage that's
the phrase
that stuck with me and i had an
opportunity
to play with two other great players and
we had known each other since we were
teenagers i've been knowing brian since
we were 16
17 years old i knew duane since we were
19
20 years old and it just fit
and it was uh it was a possibility to be
like my heroes i told you i
i idolized jordan and kobe and it was
right there to be able the calling
happened
and i wanted to play on that stage that
i was talking about i was telling you
from as i was a little kid
i was watching michael jordan i was like
i distinctly remember and even
you know the moment i found out about
basketball was because michael jordan
was playing on tv
all the time i mean even um we would go
to dayton ohio
my dad he drive us is crazy 18 hours in
a single cab pickup truck
84 f-150 man and we
he'd drive us from dallas to dayton and
drop us off
and like every summer at 91 92 93 for
sure
the night that we got to my grandma's
house
the bulls would be playing and it's
winning time you know it was in the
finals and then
i i understood after a while you know
after they get the trophy i'm like oh
wow what is
this is amazing and i wanted to do that
man and you know i couldn't even tell
you what happened the rest of that
summer
i couldn't tell you what happened that
night i couldn't even tell you who's
around the tv i know i was
and i was just taking it all in and
every year
i would watch it and watch it and watch
it and that's all i wanted to do you
know aspire to do and
and at that time that situation was
right there in front of me it was right
there in front of me to take so
i took it and that was only a chance you
know that's just a
this is just an opportunity not to even
say that you're gonna have success but
this is your best chance to go for that
right now now did you feel
100 confident when you made that
decision end
in the weeks and months following or
were there any points where you're like
oh man oh yeah there's always going to
be those points right i don't know
i don't know yeah there's those points
you get to those points but i had gotten
used to that
by then and you know for whoever is
listening sometimes it's just going to
be
like that you're supposed to feel it
right you're supposed to is a major leap
of faith yeah and if you're making that
leap of faith yeah there will be some
questions but
i always that was part of my mental
training like yeah they're just
questions that's okay let's
let's just keep going forward logically
it makes sense is sound and then yeah
when the emotions come in and
yeah you get those feelings like i don't
know if i can do this and and we came
together in such a way to where it was
explosive and
pretty infamous yeah you know so
that comes into it as well yeah you
start having self-doubt
and that's one of the things we
eventually got to with talking with the
heat
that self-doubt is going to come and
doesn't make you any less of a
competitor or person
is just a part of the process yeah yeah
i'm so i'm so glad you're mentioning
that i remember
not too long ago i was talking to really
not on the podcast this was a private
conversation but
an extremely famous investor who from
the outside looking in i'm like okay
this guy's balls are bigger than my
house like i don't know how this guy
i don't know how he does what he does
like i would
not get a second of sleep it's just
the risks that i perceive him as taking
yeah and
we were talking about self-doubt and
second guessing and he goes oh just to
be clear he's like
no matter what you're going to have some
regret he's like if you buy something
and it does really well you're going to
kick yourself for not having bought
enough why didn't i buy enough if
if you buy something and it does really
poorly you'd be like why did i invest in
that he's like oh he's like no either
way
he's like you're going to have second
guesses he's like just accept that as
like part of the game and i was like oh
it was actually very stress-relieving
yeah because a lot of people they they
get that they think something's wrong
with them
yeah or they think something's wrong
with the situation or they'll pull out
yeah and say hey no no i always kind of
think of one of my favorite books was uh
blink
blank yeah by gladwell and you know just
talking about the gut decision
stretching your gut then we talk
ourselves out of it
yeah we knew the answer yeah and we
talked ourselves out yeah
talking yourself out of it that's a part
of it it's gonna happen but
you know just stay with it stay with
what you you know said you were gonna do
what you're meant to do and
yeah sometimes self doubt comes you just
gotta be like [ __ ]
hold on i'm working now and it's okay to
dismiss that voice yeah
yeah totally doesn't doesn't mean you're
uniquely flawed
does not mean that at all when you were
reviewing
footage of yourself could you give an
example of
if one comes to mind of when you did
that and then
once again like how do you watch like
what are you
looking for and what are you seeing
because
you know someone was asking me as i was
preparing for this like well have you
watched basketball and i said
i think i've seen basketball
i'm not sure i've watched it because for
instance i mean there are sports i know
a lot more about like wrestling or
boxing or these things and i can watch
and i see things that some of my friends
won't see
just because i know the technical for
sure underpinnings absolutely
so when you're watching footage if you
can think of any examples of reviewing
your own footage
why did you look at it and then what
were you looking for
what types of things did you pick out i
think naturally every player will start
on offense
they want to watch themselves on offense
and and it can easily turn into just a
highlight tape
the instagram of your own mind you know
what i mean
your highlight tape and i would look for
mistakes
i got to the point where i was looking
for mistakes did you do that
consistently
did it start at a particular point was
it always
no not always like i said highlight type
it started off as highlight tape so you
just want to see yourself doing good but
then you get to a point
to where you're looking for the
inconsistencies or
if there was a game certain particular
game that you were unsuccessful
i'm looking at the whole game to see
what exactly
why what happened what i can do to get
better
what is this team doing they might have
had some success against me
defending me so one of the things i
would look for i would look
is so hard to describe it i would look
for everything all and once you get to
the point where you're looking for
everything but
the main main main things were
defense and offense my positioning on
offense
i would always look at my teammates
characteristics
seeing what they're doing see their what
the scouting report on them
is they might do a certain particular
move every single time
in this play and you have to watch film
to know that
it would help build continuity and we
talk about it too like when you're doing
that
i want you to zig instead of zack you
know and it's having those discussions
you watched the video with coaches with
teammates
everything by myself with the team we
always started practice with half an
hour of film oh you did
yeah 45 to an hour if spo felt
long-winded
but yeah we would that was game footage
pretty much usually the night before
looking at all the mistakes
and then i developed the habit of going
home
and dissecting other players so
in particular uh was dirk nowitzki
three-point shooter
seven feet late 90s early 2000s this is
when it was you know he was shooting
threes back when
you know it was very taboo i guess for a
big to be doing all that stuff but he
revolutionized the game in that aspect
we lost against them in the 2011 finals
terrible terrible
tragedy right but one thing it inspired
me to do
he did these certain particular moves
within the system that was
you couldn't stop it and i had to figure
out what it was he was doing
so i watched a tremendous amount of film
on him in particular
but what happened in our losing effort
but what happened was you start seeing
like you're saying you start seeing
other things
so what i started doing was i started
compartmentalizing the film
and i would say okay i'm gonna watch
what atlanta or i'm gonna watch what the
lakers are doing on
offense it became this thing of okay
i've got my offensive system down i know
my game
now i will watch film on the other team
i just want to get inside the mind of
the other team
i want to know all their plays i want to
know their best players best moves
so we can take all those things away so
that's what it became i would study
to take the top two high percentage
things away
from a team or person i have to imagine
also
that with that amount of footage and
also just that amount of time on the
court
practicing playing that you're almost
certainly absorbing
a lot more than you're consciously aware
of for sure you know what i mean for
sure
absolutely and what it's what starts
happening is
not that it happens on tap but you can
start anticipating what's going to
happen on the court
so things will just come to you and be
like i'm going to run over here because
i'm going to be
wide open or i'm going to crash the
boards cause i'm gonna get a dunk
huh and it happens yo that's just great
you know it's crazy
but you know the more it just becomes a
part of you the more that you
watch it and i was having you know those
second guesses and doubts and stuff the
other week i was talking with my buddy
and i said man i should have
i could have done more man he said okay
stop
you watch more film than anybody i know
yeah because you know film is more of a
thing a football term yeah so it's kind
of like the quarterback and football
they have to watch a tremendous amount
of film because they have to it's really
anticipation
they have to anticipate they have to
look where they're looking and say okay
this is what they're doing if you watch
enough film
you'll pick up on people's tendencies
and you know what they're about to do
before they do it because he's leaning a
little
those subconscious things that you pick
up telegraph you know like i say you
would be
surprised how much success you have as a
defender
if you take the best move away yeah
every day i watch film
whether it's the team or the player and
be like okay
take away that for him he goes right
every single time he's got to go left
today and if he scores 30 points going
left hey i'm gonna tip my hat to him but
percentage that's where we would
mess with the data you know we would
play with the numbers we twist the
numbers a little bit
and team-wise and individual wise you
develop a repetition for knowing the
team's plays that's that's the biggest
thing right
that's gotta really mess with people it
does you know it's just two minutes in
the fourth quarter and they call a play
it's like he's going right there
a lot of people look at lebron and be
like oh my god you know
these were the discussions we were
having yeah yeah every day
lebron james shane battier ray allen
dwyane wade
richard lewis myself we're talking about
i guess a master class every day and how
to stop people or
you know how to be successful take away
one leg of the stool you know
if they beat us with two legs then hey
man that's a good job but
probably not yeah yeah it's uh the
footage
is so important in the fight game too
whether it's boxing or mma
same story also because i guess like
many sports
like if you have person a versus person
b
and a beats b and b beats c it doesn't
automatically mean that a is going to
beat c
right for sure match ups yeah styles and
you know and styles and
another component to that is
you might play a team like san antonio
which we were duking it out with them
for a couple years and
they'll run certain plays against
certain teams they have certain set
plays against
you that they think are successful and
you have to crack those codes and and
figure that out
on top of the individual tendencies for
a minor ginobili for tony parker for tim
duncan for danny green you know you have
to
you have to know their individual
tendencies on top of the team tendency
so it can get it can get pretty deep you
know you like you're saying getting the
weeds you can be in the weeds
yeah uh manu is such a he's a sweet guy
doesn't i yeah he's close to here lives
nearby he'll dunk on you too
well it's definitely talking about
that was the thing about the spurs maybe
like man nice guys
well you know he's elbowed me in the
face a few times so you know
the nice guy you know gentlemen
yeah he's a hell of a competitor
yeah let's talk about letters to a young
athlete
this is your new book why
books are hard books are hard yeah
books are hard you know how did this
come about
so i was i was just in a place i got the
news the unexpected news that i wouldn't
be playing
anymore and and i was just kind of in a
place
and i was just not wandering around but
reshuffling the deck
yeah you know that's great we put it
getting used to
being a father in the household being a
husband in the household all the time
i never knew how much time that i had
given to basketball
people think things are easy and like
could she just write a book i remember
people were saying you should write a
book like what am i going to write about
i didn't even know what to even think
about but i just put it to the side and
really didn't think too much of it but
always being an avid reader
i guess it was somewhere in the back of
my mind
i continued to think about it and i was
in a period whether
i liked it or not of reflecting i had
never reflected
on my career you're too busy yeah you're
just in it
you're too busy playing and going to the
next thing and going from a to z
and i find myself in um you know just
reflecting on the journey and how
that child from hutchins texas was able
to actually
jump from lilypad to lilypad and make it
to the nba and actually be successful
and thinking about those who helped me
along my path and
all the coaches who said the wise words
to me friends who helped me out
my family of course that helped me out
my wife
and i was in deep reflection and then
you know the opportunity came
we just kept talking about it kept
talking about it
i have agents and they were like yeah
man you know just keep talking about yo
think about it and
yo you should meet ryan we should be
ryan holiday oh yeah i've read a few of
his books man
that's cool so we met right down the
street here in austin
and we hit it off we had like a three
hour lunch just sitting talking and
and you know shooting the [ __ ] and we
had a great time and
and then i said okay great let's figure
this out and there's no reason to talk
to anybody
else he was the first person that we
interviewed
to help us out and from then on we just
were bouncing ideas it took months and
months and months
just to even figure out you know what
are we gonna write about but
sitting there and being open to thinking
of myself
in that position of not being a player
and
thinking of what would be the book that
i wanted to read
before a game if i were a younger player
today
so this is kind of that book that i
wanted to read and you know one of
my favorite parts about books like that
is that they always translated
you know whether that was uh whether
you're an athlete whether you're a ceo a
leader a follower a librarian a teacher
we wanted to have those basic
principles that apply to everything
whether you're a young athlete or old
athlete
we wanted to have those lessons
from myself that have actually helped me
and worked
and you know from people that i admire
tools that have gotten them through
challenges i think that's the biggest
thing there are challenges every day
everybody goes through challenges
and this is a book to give you those
tools to hopefully rise to the occasion
when it comes yeah who are some of the
people you admire whose advice
you have featured in the book spo of
course
eric spoelstra is in there my coach
leonard bishop we
talk about some things like that one of
one of my good friends is candace parker
um she's in you know chicago now uh
getting ready for her season
but she's such a tremendous athlete and
a person
and we were having a particular
discussion one time just about
and really just a female player what
they have to go through
we were in beijing
and the whole female team have to win
the squad they have to go to their
respective places to go
start a season not in the states
not home they're going to russia they're
going to spain
from beijing china and they just finish
playing a whole summer
or they'll finish the season in wnba and
then go right back to us so they were
summer spring fall winter they're
playing year round and they don't even
get the credit for that
that was just so inspiring to hear
because you know it's like ali candace
man you
man you really it just doesn't stop it
never stops i know it doesn't stop for
me and i know how i feel how do you you
know
how do you feel and just kind of um
you know hearing her story and how she
gets through that she i don't think she
does it anymore i don't think she plays
in europe anymore but when she was just
you know hearing those stories and how
to actually get through that
and be successful and still be the mvp
and still compete for a championship
in both leagues that was tremendous and
of course
pat riley he's always been um a great
motivator and mentor for me
and um we i had a discussion with him
kind of jumping back to the book thing
he um
he was one of those uh encouragers too
he should write a book
and he said yeah you don't have to think
about it now but
just think about it you know this is
what i did when i wrote my book the
winner within
i was going through this and yeah it's a
good thing you should you should check
it out
and you know this was a casual lunch in
malibu yeah you know i
really didn't think anything of it but
he's always been uh you know that person
to really
uh be an example and um you know he's
one of my heroes
and you know you read the forward too
it's so cool yeah that's really amazing
turns out he's like a huge writer he he
empathized with me quite a bit because
his career like mine whether it was
because of other people's opinion or
professionally being able to
withstand the athleticism that the the
new league was coming or whatever his
career just abruptly ended just like
mine
and you know he is a writer as well and
he told me about his writing experiences
and you know he's got a few books out
there and he's even wrote screenplays
and stuff like that so
it gave me the openness to accept other
things and
and say well okay just get the wheels
turning well
if i were to write a book what would it
be about and you know it
two and a half year process man before
you know it two and a half years later
two and a half years but going and
looking within
to to try and find those stories and
those principles
to what has made me me you mentioned pat
a few times what do you think his
superpower is or
superpowers motivation yeah and
excellence
so a lot of people try to be motivating
yeah right
so he's good at it he's good at it why
is he good at it
well yeah the experience yeah like
what's the experience he's got the
experience i think when you're in team
sports for so long
and you've seen every level
whether that's good or bad yeah and
everything in between
i think you can kind of start collect
things that work and things that don't
work
and you know in the nba you're around
each other every day
and i'm sure there have been plenty of
things that he said that didn't work
those get left on the cutting room yeah
it's like yeah okay that's okay that's
all right and you know but you know his
experience like crickets
okay we're gonna cut that one from the
number one yeah they didn't care for
that one in practice so we'll you know
move on from it but he's an extensive
notetaker i know that
a voracious reader and you know
talking to people i think that's one of
the biggest things actually having that
relationship and having those
conversations
and sitting down to talk with a person
because if you come in just trying to be
a motivator
why you know you have to have a why
in things that you do and sometimes it
can backfire if you're trying too hard
to be a motivator
it can come off as phony and people are
very smart they can pick up one
pick up on those things pat he's always
had that open door policy he's always
been one of those guys you just knock on
his door and talk
it can be intimidating a lot of people
don't do it
it can be it's like going to the
principal's office you know
but um he has always been open i mean
you know
many dinners lunches talking dissecting
the game and he wants to be great
i think um a lot of people can work on
their appetite to be great and that
doesn't necessarily mean
having a bunch of money or having a
bunch of
tremendous amount of success that could
be man i'm coming here i'm being
consistent i'm working every day
i'm putting in the work my mental
preparation is good i'm ready
to carry out this task for this goal
having this unified goal and going after
it i think sometimes it's
being as simple as that can be a
tremendous help
for a lot of people but with pat he once
he identifies the goal
i mean he goes after it passionately and
wholeheartedly and and that's
when you get into the teeth of it when
you're in the foxhole that's when the
passion comes out you know
you can't really motivate someone and
you just met him or
it's going good yeah that's right
naturally going you want to motivate
somebody when it's tough
and you have to be in there with them
suffering yeah
the shared vibration yeah not to be too
dramatic but yeah you gotta
you gotta take part in the suffering to
get over the hump
this is gonna be a strange segue but i'm
going to do it i'm going to i'm going to
strong
on this one we'll probably um go for
just a few more questions
true or false i read that you are a fan
of leonardo da vinci
sam okay please please tell me more why
how did that come about i can't remember
how it
really happened of course everybody
knows the mona lisa and uh
and the famous uh inventions and things
that he had
i got my hands on one of the books about
his notebook
and i read it it was amazing
i love italy i we went to rome we took
an early
i went to rome pretty early in my career
around 2007
2008 somewhere in there and so the
fascination was already there i got to
see the coliseum and i was already
infatuated with those things and i got
to see that
one way or another i start yeah reading
books and i read the biography walter
isaacson wrote oh that's great that's a
good one
this is amazing but i guess you know you
were kind of alluding to learning to
learn
and the pushing the human mind and all
that stuff i was just
always fascinated by that so naturally
he just became a person to
you know emulate the polymath of poly
mass means the
the breadth of his fascination yeah
is just fascinating and and also and i
and
i know that you know this but if you
look at the entire
pie chart let's just say of his
completed works
or actually should say his works and the
percentage that were completed versus
incomplete very high percentage
incomplete
for sure and that's kind of as a perfect
segue actually i kind of had to
come to appreciate that because one
could consider
a lot of his unfinished work to be a
masterpiece yeah
you know and that's kind of how i look
at my career because it was
you know in my opinion it was unfinished
it's finished but it was still an
unfinished painting in my opinion
and that kind of gave me a little little
confidence too like yeah he didn't even
finish all his paintings you guys you
know
that was just davinci people yeah you
know what i mean and
you know one of the cool things uh me
and my wife we love to vacation
getting to see those things in person i
mean i'm gonna have a notetaker and i
doodle and draw and you know have
sketchbooks all over the place so that
was a natural connection right there
but then seeing actually seeing
the paintings we saw the mona lisa in
person
we saw the last supper in person which
they were
so nice and gave us a private tour milan
and when you see it is have you seen it
i have not
it's bigger than the size of this wall
people can't see it but
i thought it was like more of a yeah
yeah around the arm and
like tim ferriss armed arm man that
thing is huge it's the whole side of a
building
and it was just breathtaking and just
got away it's like
but seeing these relics and all of these
things that
still you know stood the test of time
and he's still
actually here today and and just seeing
that it was very inspiring
i was always fascinated in the
renaissance you know in the renaissance
period and knowing that the houses were
right down the street
so you could go and go study under
michelangelo and be a sculptor
yeah and you could go under da vinci and
be a painter and it's right
all right there in this small little
space outside of florence or in florence
or whatever i can't remember
yeah but just just thinking of the
density is crazy crazy you know so it
showed me that things are possible
that you could do was just through his
observation and extensive note-taking
and curiosity
you know i try to embody those things
yeah yeah and yeah these
also these incredible inventions and
part of the reason this is
reasonably fresh on the mind is that
i've interviewed walter isaacson a few
times and interviewed him about his da
vinci book
and some of his inventions were just
these
prescient accurate predictors of the
future yeah like hundreds of years later
and a lot of them were terrible like
they never would have worked and you
would not want to be wearing his
you know a mock-up for uh bird wings and
jump off a cliff
right and i think that's also very
inspiring in a way right because he had
these masterpieces
that were masterpieces despite the fact
that they were incomplete maybe in some
ways that makes them even all the more
interesting
and he also had misfires mm-hmm right so
it's
like if if leo is allowed to have both
of those
yeah maybe we should be like that's okay
and i'd love to hear your thoughts and i
apologize if you've been asked this a
million times but
i think for people listening your story
has
many different points that can be
inspiring
the one that i think everyone can
identify with
certainly is points in life when you
realize that certain things are within
your control
and certain things are outside of your
control in fact a lot of things and
so you have this pulmonary embolism
and for reasons or for causes
perhaps partly known partially unknown
that marked the beginning of an end of a
career
are there any particular books or
resources or advice or anything that
helped you through that period i mean
what was it like emotionally
when you realized okay i can't actually
forestall this any longer like this
this is it it happened in stages i knew
i wasn't going to play again for sure
all the way when uh it's a player by the
name of gordon hayward
he's still playing to this day thank
goodness he dislocated his ankle
i hadn't played the year before and i
still had dreams and aspirations
of playing in the nba and i mean that
took all the wind out of myself
first game of the season first five
minutes of me watching that season i was
like
let me watch basketball i'm gonna get
back into it
because i'm playing this season
somebody's gonna pick me up
and that's a dislocated ankle
you know in that game in that game i
hadn't watched basketball in close to a
year
first game that i watched god dislocates
his ankle and i mean whatever motivation
that i had
instantly went away and i said ah man
that could be me
boy those workouts just weren't as
intense after that
in the midst of figuring these things
out
i can't remember what i read but it was
pretty much trusting everything that i
read
and all of these books that say find
what you love to do
you gotta love you gotta love it
and it sounds great until you're put in
that position right yeah
and so i found myself kind of asking
well
what do i love to do basketball okay
what else i had to answer that question
i didn't know
anything else and i had to deal with the
preconceived notion that i guess
people think i'm smart which is great
like oh chris you'll be fine
you'll figure it out but in that moment
yeah you still have to figure it out and
so i said i would find myself sitting
around okay let me answer this question
what else do i love doing and that's
where music
came in and i always wanted to learn
how to play an instrument it was one of
those things where i gave up
like two or three times in my teens and
20s
so i said man you know what this time
i'm gonna pick it up and i'm not gonna
put it down and i'm gonna learn how to
play i'm gonna learn how to play an
instrument
which instrument the guitar i started
with the guitar let me ask this
really naive question i'm just looking
at the size of your hands
compared to my hands is it harder for
you to form
chords on an on a on a scale
guitar yeah it is a little right
which is the same not core structure but
it's the same string string
patterns and everything the notes it's
all the same system so you know yeah
i've
recently gotten into bass in the last
few weeks and months
but yeah i mean i wanted to learn how to
play the guitar man and
i said man i've always i've never
stopped does it make any sense
of course it doesn't make any sense but
i love it
this is i love it i was watching the
rolling stones it was on tv
playing there doesn't need to make sense
well into their life and they're still
doing shows i said i want to do that i
do that for free and then
i found myself my wife and i we we had
our we were already avid music lovers
and stuff like that
we cranked it up a notch we went to rock
festivals with the
went to coachella glastonbury bonnaroo
going to see certain shows you know
meeting all of these cool musicians and
just doing something different and i
mean it was just
it was amazing and i started getting
magical feelings and
those things that magic that you want to
pursue it didn't make any sense at the
time i just knew it felt good
and so that opened up a new world of
possibility to me and
you know i started making uh more
friends making um
great connections music is one of those
things that
really do bring people together and it's
a live element to it it's a recorded
element to it it's just
all these different elements that you
could put together or keep separate and
just really enjoy it
and so then i found myself you know okay
playing the guitar then i wanted to make
beats
then it just went out to full-fledged
productions and and writing sessions and
stuff like that but
continuing to go on and meeting great
people rico love is a great friend of
mine uh
miguel the artist miguel is a great
friend of mine meeting billy corbin
and meeting collective soul having beers
after their show
you know and and just hanging out
there's some atlanta georgia boys you
know we're
connecting with so many different people
in so many different ways was
was really really cool and especially
here in austin it's been great you know
gary clark we met him a few years ago
but just i was just so enamored by how
they could play the guitar man and just
do all these cool things so that's just
really been a thing that has actually
turned into something but has been great
for the spirit
what would you aside from trying to find
the thing that lights you up inside
because i'm sure you had some dark
moments too i would imagine sure for
sure for someone who's going through
an experience like that maybe there's
something they had planned that they no
longer
can pursue yeah maybe they had a career
or a relationship or something end and
now they just feel this void and they
just feel
directionless not necessarily hopeless
but just really unsure of what to do
what advice might you give them or what
would you say to them be open
i spoke with a friend i won't name who
they are i was having one of those days
right just in the dumps and i was taking
this trip and i was uh doing some work
and um
this particular person was running a
network
and uh running a company the ceo and um
you know i was feeling all bad and stuff
and i said man you know how do you know
it's a
brilliant person i want to get some
insight first thing that person said was
well
i was a child with cancer and when you
really do
go through a situation to where
you're going to wear hair or no hair you
truly do find out that is up on you to
make a choice to enjoy it or be happy or
attempt to get yourself going
and when they said that i was like man
all these problems
that i feel that i have and this person
just told me they were a kid with cancer
so that kind of made me realize like
okay
put everything to the side this person
just told me
that it is really our choice not
necessarily that
bad things won't happen or life won't
throw curve balls or things happen or
you won't be in a rut
it's just that when you're in this rut
it's on you
to get out of it and to actually have
confidence now
people can help you but one of the
things that we always said in basketball
if you were like on a shitty team one of
the worst experiences to have
because you know you're losing and then
you're feeling bad inside but then
you're making money and it's good money
and
people are like oh you're fine yeah it's
like this paradox
but like we always used to say hey look
nobody's coming through that door
if you're waiting on that perfect person
or that perfect utopian moment to come
it's not you got to start putting work
in now
pick yourself up self-motivation right
yeah you got to get yourself going and
then
you'd be surprised things start
happening yeah but you can't
sit in the bed feeling sorry for
yourself that's like one of the toughest
things to do
sorry with all these basketball
analogies but
i think it's you know five game losing
streak
one of the hardest things to do is to
bounce back and actually win a game
because it's hard
start watching basketball watch a bad
team play
they have a chance to win the game
they're in the game one bad thing will
happen and they just
oh the body language the shoulders start
slouching
people start no no keep playing yeah
okay you
you know it's a couple things that hurt
or it's a couple things that
hell it sucks let's get that out the way
it
sucks right now but we're not gonna know
pity parties
you know that that becomes uh being old
very fast
and you do see success that's not going
to take away the challenges
you know you're still going to be you're
still going to be faced with challenges
daily
but if you get into the mindset to where
you say okay hey problem solution look
in the mirror
what am i going to do right now because
i'm going to stop feeling sorry for
myself because it's so easy right you
could just
oh man you know the coach oh
they they did it oh man uh
after a while it gets old yeah and i
assume if someone's listening to this
now even if they're in a place where
they
don't want to be in frustrated with it
it's a daily grind but it's not going to
happen tomorrow
you got to make that decision start
focusing start visualizing and start
working toward that goal and know
just because you had this moment of
thought and say okay i'm going for it
the c's aren't going to part you know
it's just not going to just open up for
you and say okay chris great yeah that's
what you wanted
why did you ask it's not like that
you've got to be consistent be diligent
and just know that the challenge is
going to come and when these things
arise again i'm not going to feel sorry
for myself
we're going to win this game even when
it gets hard and then we're going to do
it again
and again and again and again and just
you know get to that point
that's a great story well you had it is
when you had that conversation with this
i guess network exec do you recall what
the next thing was that you did when you
were like oh wow
okay that puts things in perspective i
stopped complaining
yeah i knew i was i didn't know i was
complaining but i i heard myself i heard
my language sometimes you gotta listen
to yourself
and this was me after me promising
myself that i wouldn't complain after i
came from africa i went to africa we
went to joburg we went out to clip town
and soweto
and solve real poverty yeah went to
india
speaking of being the nba global
ambassador we went to places and we have
seen real poverty you know that make the
projects look like a five-star hotel
and so when i saw those things and you
take in all that stuff it's like man
it's heavy
what have i been complaining about i
haven't been complaining
uh man i've been complaining a little
bit when she said that i
instantly stopped feeling sorry for
myself and said okay
at the end of the day yeah 13 years in
the league
and i've got a shot at doing something
else that's all i need
i don't need the like i say that leader
to come by and say no chris let me tell
you something
kick the door in and just get me going
that right there was kind of like oh man
i felt bad
you know for even having not weakness
not points of weakness but just like
having those thoughts and just saying
like what do people say when if you
think you've got problems with everybody
put their problems on the table you'll
pick yours back up real quick
[Laughter]
never heard that that's great it's kind
of that's pretty much what it was like
okay i got some problems with man okay
i'll take those back
yeah how you feeling fine i'm doing
great
uh i'm so glad that they were having
this conversation
it's so easy to complain and yeah
i feel like i've been complaining a lot
in the last handful of weeks and it's
it's socially reinforced you will find
somebody if you go searching
who's going to encourage you oh yeah
you're right to feel that way oh that's
terrible and then how do you feel right
yeah how do you feel when you're doing
it that's for people listening
to you know and make you look at who's
around you a little more
yeah it's because it's like yeah yeah
it's tough and it sucks it's been like
that for years but aren't you tired of
it
yeah you sick and tired of being sick
and tired yeah right after a while
it's not going to change yeah these
habits that you're building you got to
think about the habits that you're
building what
and i tell people too be conscious of
what you're consuming especially
nowadays
you know i tell my kids that i try to
you know even for myself you know just
with everything you can consume it's a
lot of bs yeah you know so just be aware
of what you're putting into your mind
what you're thinking about
and yeah birds like a feather right if
you're you find yourself complaining and
yeah you people like sap
you can have pity party but after a
while they're gonna get tired of you
complaining they're gonna complain
about you
you know so it just you just get to a
point where it's like okay hey man let's
talk about solutions yeah you know let's
talk about solutions how do we get
out of this rut or how do we find
that next thing to do for me music and
writing i would have looked at you like
you had eight heads
five six years ago music maybe five
years ago
not so much writing yeah i always did
them
but just thinking of that i wouldn't
have even
come close at that time but going
through
challenges and situations you want to
you want to come out better
right you don't want to still be holed
up talking about what could have been or
why it didn't happen
that gets old after a while so ladies
and gentlemen if chris bosh
can have these days you can too but it's
about what you actually do in response
to those days and you know that long
time ago
you're inspiring me i'm gonna do it
again i read a short book
it was called the 21 day no complaint
experiment
written by a pastor will bowman i think
is the name
and it's just a commitment to not
complain for 21 days
and it had a huge impact and uh
i am going to do that because like you
said if you were to put your
problems on the table with even a small
subset of humankind you'd be like i'll
take those back yeah
thanks thanks no nobody take my problem
cookies i want those i'm going home with
those
and uh it really does make a tremendous
difference
and i think that letters to a young
athlete is going to do a lot of good i'm
very excited about this
i am thrilled you took the time to do it
properly
two and a half years when i hear people
like yeah we started riding three months
later we were done i was like
don't send it to me and hey look what i
had preferred it to be one
one and a half sure we had the intention
but you know the
the process is the process right the
process is the process you go through
you know and we've been hands on yeah
from the jump this has been so special
to me
but it's like uh i was joking the other
day uh you said in in writing about a
book overcoming obstacles
we had to overcome obstacles writing the
book
[Laughter]
you know that was you know that was a
good one man and
it was uh it was such a it was a
tremendous process and i think a lot of
people will really really be able to
take something for themselves no matter
what they do they'll be able to take
something for themselves because you
know it's been a team effort through and
through
it's been one of those things to where
i'm talking about people that i admire
and situations that i admire from my own
life that was like oh yeah in the moment
you're just
doing it but then reflecting on it it's
like oh yeah
that conversation that i had with my
coach
back when i was 21 that would set off
these ripple effects cut off the ripple
effect so i wouldn't freak out
yeah yeah it's uh it makes me happy you
took the time
i remember somebody said to me at one
point i was struggling
as i do with any writing and i was
struggling through book
and they said oh you're 90 done
congratulations you only have 50
left and i was like
yeah wait a minute wait a minute they're
like and they're like yeah you'll see
you'll see what i mean you'll see that
no that's great and
i think you know athlete is an
interesting term
and letters to a young athlete you might
even
say letters to a young competitor and
people might be inclined to say well i'm
not a competitor and i would say
you are even if you don't compete with
other people there's a competition
like we've been discussing between your
lesser selves
and your better self absolutely yeah
we're all in the game everybody's in
there and and you know it's you know
like i said giving you the tools and
teamwork is definitely one of uh one of
the main tools of course mental
preparation
self-motivation getting yourself ready
and going but
teamwork yeah working with others
learning how to coexist
with people going after that goal
definitely i think that's a huge huge
important thing that we definitely
definitely talk about because
going to miami playing with the best two
players in the world
so my eagle had to take a back seat
i came in thinking i was going to be the
number one scorer
in the league definitely in miami
only because i said man they can score
but i can score two and they're going to
be making plays for me
that was in my head but the math doesn't
work
you know you're going to have to learn
how to coexist within this structure
being the third peg on the stool nothing
wrong with that
but fighting that notion that that
actually means something putting the
team before yourself and
you know making those tough decisions
that you have to make
because it doesn't feel good but the
team is done so hey chris you need to
play the center guard these bigger dudes
because you're the only one that can do
it
rebound the ball and get it to these
guys like no no i want to score
you know you give me the ball no no you
must have it wrong
you get me the ball and everybody else
get out the way that's how we did it
and it's not necessarily the case if you
want to be successful so that's like
always kind of a thing that
always took very importantly and took
the heart
if you're going after a championship or
legacy or greatness or something like
that
and you're part of a team the team has
to come before
the person and what's best for the team
you know might not
be best for your ego sometimes and you
have to be okay with that
and you got to tell you you go take the
backseat let yourself take the backseat
we're going to be champions man
yeah sometimes that's what it takes yeah
man if you want to go
fast go alone if you want to go far go
together
and together man chris bosh at chris
bosh on twitter
also on instagram chris bosh official
chris
bosh on facebook the new book is
letters to a young athlete i've really
enjoyed this conversation it's so nice
to meet you
same here nice meeting you and uh is
there anything else you'd like to
to say to the audience any other
requests comments questions anything
you'd like to add before we
before we wrap up oh man i just love
starting a discussion i think that's
what the future
is really going to be about so i want
this book
to be a discussion and really you know
all books and just
be a civilized discussion where we can
see where each other's coming from
because i think nowadays you know things
get polarized and kind of
either taken out of context or being too
much i want everyone to know how
important this book is
to me but with that said we want to
start the conversation
of how to be great breaking those things
down
how to constantly uh get over those
challenges like i keep alluding to
that are coming and to have those open
discussions and just continue to push
the boundaries in a positive great way
but
let everybody know they can do it if
they have that thing do it
don't wait and you can do it look in the
mirror don't complain
man problem solution look in the mirror
problem in solution letters to a young
athlete
is the book and i'm excited for you
that's a it's a big accomplishment i
know how much
effort goes into it and i'm thrilled
that people will get to
learn also the principles right you'll
have stories but also the principles
that you've applied
not just to one thing but to many things
even though you are best known for one
thing
and i think you know in a way the the
obstacles that you've faced
within the context of a book like this
are a tremendous gift
because there are battles
everyone is fighting that we know
nothing about you've had to
face and overcome obstacles yourself and
i think that is incredibly humanizing
also
absolutely and that's what you know you
know i like to call the pillars
of uh getting through things you know
the pillars of success that's kind of
like my work entitled for it you know
it's perseverance
mental preparation rising to the
occasion teamwork
is is a huge oven visualization is a
huge because i feel in my life
everything that's happened i always saw
it in my mind's eye first and
did hours and hours and hours of
imagining and um you know then it's time
to put in the work after that and
you can't just sit there and dream about
it you just gotta go out there and do it
and you know
work be calculated of course you just
can't go out there with no goal and just
run around like a chicken with your head
cut off but you can't identify that goal
and then work backwards and say okay
what do i need to do
and work hard at those things yeah one
step at a time chris thank you so much
for taking the time thank you man i'm uh
so glad to be on here it's great i've
been listening for years and it's great
to be on here
really cool i hope it fits yeah it does
fit it's it's great to spend some time
together
and for everybody listening we will have
links to everything
including letters to a young athlete uh
in the show notes at 10. blog forward
slash
podcast easy to find and until next time
thank you for tuning in hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the uh the world of the
esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
theragun i have two theraguns
and they're worth their weight and gold
i've been using them every single day
whether you're an elite athlete or just
a regular person trying to get through
your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom
of my feet it's helped with my plantar
fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it in fact
as massage reinvented on some level
helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this and the all new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet it's easy to use
and about as quiet as an electric
toothbrush it's pretty astonishing
you really have to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app
an incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragun.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine
use them on their it bands after long
runs there are a million ways to use it
and the gen fourth era guns
start at just 199 i said i have two
i have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragun.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
tonal that's t
o t-o-n-a-l tonal is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer that's the tagline from their
website folks
so it gives you the one sentence summary
by eliminating traditional metal weights
tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance in a device smaller than a
flat screen tv
it mounts right on your wall with no
floor space required
i've had one for a few months now after
a number of close friends
recommended tonal to me and it allows me
to do things that i would normally need
a huge gym for
like cable chop and lift or rotational
exercises and it allows me to do
other things that are nearly impossible
otherwise
like eccentric loading which i'll talk
about again later
tonal is precision engineered and
designed to be the world's most advanced
strength studio and personal trainer it
uses breakthrough technology like
adaptive digital weights
and ai learning together with the best
experts in resistance training so you
can get stronger faster one of my
friends who used to be a competitive
skier
very high level competitive skier has
doubled his strength in many exercises
over a period of months
so what are these adaptive digital
weights tonal's patented
digital weight system makes thousands of
calculations a second to deliver you a
smooth weightlifting experience using
their advanced electronic
motor technology and a lot of the
buttons are built right
into the handles themselves into the
grips so you don't need to move around
and it is extremely easy to use
tonal lets you adjust the weight in one
pound increments and you can do it on
the fly
something that was never possible with
traditional dumbbells it's easy to dial
weights up and down with just the touch
of a button tonal also has built-in
dynamic weight modes
like chains eccentric and their
patent-pending smart flex technology
so you can experiment with more ways to
get stronger faster without the hassle
of extra equipment like chains and bands
the eccentrics which i mentioned means
that you can
set a mode that allows you to say just
as an example bicep curl
15 pounds up and then lower
automatically
20-25 pounds down and it is incredible
how much you can get done in just a
handful of minutes
when you use this type of technology so
check it out
tritonal t-o-n-a-l the world's smartest
home gym for 30 days in your home and if
you don't love it
you can return it for a full refund
visit www.tonal.com
tonal.com and for a limited time get 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code
tim21 like i'm ready for
my first drink at checkout that's
www.tonaltonal.com
promo code tim 21 tim21
tonal be your strongest